some of the biggest communication
challenges we face take place
interpersonally giving feedback
revealing personal information
apologizing
the key to addressing these tricky
communications issues is to connect and
foster mutually respectful relationships
yet many of us have never learned how to
initiate build and sustain these types
of relationships
hello i'm matt abrahams and i teach
strategic communication at stanford
graduate school of business
welcome to think fast talk smart the
podcast
to learn more about the importance of
connection and how to foster deep
personal relationships i am thrilled to
be joined by carol robin and david
bradford who both taught the wildly
popular gsb class interpersonal dynamics
also known as touchy feely
together they have just written the book
connect building exceptional
relationships with family friends and
colleagues
thank you carol and david for being here
glad to be here for having us
first off
congrats on your book i really enjoyed
reading it you know i assess the value
of a book by how many clear takeaways i
can immediately put into practice and by
that measure your book was a huge
success shall we get started let's go
absolutely all right
so carol in your book you and david talk
about exceptional relationships
what does this mean and what advice do
you have to help people develop
exceptional relationships in business
an exceptional relationship is one in
which both parties can feel
uh be vulnerable with each other and
more fully known by each other they can
be honest with each other and trust that
their disclosures won't be used against
them they can deal with conflict
productively
they both are committed uh and remain
committed to their
um to their to each other's growth and
development and it's the presence of the
combination of those things that makes
the relationship exceptional
what are a key a few key takeaways you
think that can help us build these
relationships
so the first key is to recognize that if
you're going to have a relationship like
we're talking about you have to
build the capacity to pick up two
signals from two different antenna one
antenna is what's going on for me
internally the other antenna is what's
going on for someone else
and the more those signals are the more
you're attuned to those signals and the
more they inform the choices you make in
your interaction with someone the more
likely you are to move towards
exceptional
i'm going to i'm going to really quickly
say
there's
there are three other keys one is take
the risk of allowing yourself to be
known
because the other person will be more
likely to do the same thing
be prepared to update your beliefs and
assumptions about what makes you
effective particularly as a leader
and treat every interaction as a
learning opportunity
i really like that last point uh we we
can learn so much and yet we tend to get
distracted by just focusing on what we
want to accomplish
uh that we don't take the opportunity to
really see each opportunity as something
we can learn from and and that goes to
the first point you made about thinking
about not just what is going on for you
but also think about what's going on for
the other person or people you're
talking to so thank you for that advice
i think that's very clear and very
helpful
david uh one theme in the classes you've
taught and in your book is the
importance of agency and choice
why is this so important in building
relationships
it's actually very crucial for a couple
of reasons
one is
think of the difference between somebody
saying they're talking about a
relationship with a friend
and they say
i can't raise it
i choose not to raise it
it's a world of difference
first i'm disempowering myself
i'm helpless
i'm controlled by the environment or by
the other person
the second person second reason is
i'm owning
that i have agency i'm an active
participant
now i may not choose to raise that
but it is a choice
so whenever the students or even our
friends because we drive our friends
crazy
and we come in and say no
you're choosing not to do that you may
want to not do it but it's a choice
now the second reason why this is
important is if i own that it's a choice
it gets me into further exploration
i choose not to raise this point with
charlie
i wonder why
is it charlie
is it me
do i need his impr uh his approval
what am i concerned about
and that in essence is both a source of
learning
but it's also uh gives me further
choices
as for example
i may be afraid that um
he's going to uh deny it
oh that gets me to think about how i'm
going to raise it and also how i might
respond
so really
owning the fact that i have choice
gives me freedom
empowers me
makes me an active learning participant
so in essence giving yourself permission
to feel that agency allows you so much
more freedom in the relationship and to
reflect and to to motivate yourself to
act and and i can clearly see how that
would help if you simply feel like you
can't do something and you don't have
control that's going to change the the
dynamic completely
totally totally
you both advocate for the importance of
disclosure in building stronger
relationships aren't there downsides to
letting yourself be known being honest
and raising disengagements can one of
you share some best practices that can
help us disclose in a productive and
safe manner
take a shot at the first half of that
question and then
maybe ask david if he'd like to offer up
uh some tips around the second half sure
i would argue
there's a bigger downside to not
allowing yourself to be uh to be known
for a number of reasons first of all
human beings like to make sense of
things
and the less i tell you about me the
more opportunity i give you to make up
stories about me
um
so um
second of all
if if i don't tell you much about me
you're less likely to tell me much about
you
and to the extent that that are moving
towards an exceptional relationship
requires both of us to be willing to
allow ourselves to be more known
we're moving in the wrong direction
and third i'd say that
uh the downside of not being honest
and not raising disagreements is you
have more dysfunction in the
relationship
so uh to for for best practices maybe
david's got a couple suggestions
well what i would uh build on what you
think carol very nicely said
is to acknowledge that uh matt is right
there is a risk here
there's always a risk so in your
question you said are there
safe ways
i there's nothing that's completely safe
what one can do is lower the probability
of it going south
always a risk and this is why we stress
in the book and we stress in the class
the willingness to take a risk because
that's where you learn
but i think one of the ways to look at
it is we talk about the 15 rule
and i want you to think of three
concentric circles
the inner one smallest one is my comfort
zone
where i can operate and feel perfectly
safe
but i'm not taking any risk
and we urge people to
take a 15 risk which is the next ring
around this this center one
and that's uh where i'm not sharing
everything
but i'm 15
out of my comfort zone and a little
uncomfortable
now if this doesn't go well it's
probably not a disaster
but in all likelihood it's going to go
well
but it's only 15
i don't move to the third ring which is
a danger zone
but if the second if my fifteen percent
works well
as carol says you might share fifteen
percent but i might share another
fifteen percent
so it's a gradual building process
where we find out what is working with
each other we're both taking some risks
but we're not um threatening the entire
relationship
i like that so it sounds like there's
reciprocal risk taking and in many ways
i like the concentric circle model
because i think at least for me i often
think about disclosure as binary either
i disclose or i don't but what i hear
you saying is that the choices you can
make that allow you to disclose some
and then you it's in essence an
experiment a test to see the response
and and i like that and it feeds back to
your previous response david about
agency it makes you feel in control
because sometimes disclosing you feel
like
you're you're totally out of control so
i like that a lot
but if i could add something sure it
ties in
your point about
when we think of disclosing we often
think of disclosing as the way i put it
something illegal immoral or fat we've
done in the past
and what we find in the course
is the disclosing feelings
is the most powerful way to communicate
oh wow
communicate just thoughts
and feelings you know am i feeling
uncomfortable
am i feeling worried about where we are
those are often the 15 risk
that builds the relationship because you
know what's important to me
and i would add there's a reason the
students call the course touchy
feely the import because the importance
of feelings in communication
is underscored and highlighted for an
entire quarter
including the fact that they all receive
a vocabulary of feelings
as part of the as part of the syllabus
and by the way it's an appendix in the
book connect
that's great because i think a lot of us
might resonate with what you just said
about sharing feelings but might not
have the language or the tools to do it
so it's great that there's a guide that
can help
so carol one of the first times i heard
you speak was on the topic of feedback
and i have to tell you i was just
totally transfixed by what you were
saying and in that conversation you
stressed the value of feedback and said
that feedback is a gift yet most people
resist giving or receiving it
why is that and what can people do to
get better about their feedback
well this is going to tie in a moment to
to feelings the feelings we were talking
about but let me start by why
most people have experience
stepping in a pile of doo doo when they
either tried to give somebody feedback
somebody tried to give them feedback
they observed a feedback exchange
and so what happens is david likes to
say a cat never sits on a hot stove
twice but it never sits on a cold stove
again either
so
what happens is we don't get better at
giving feedback
by not giving feedback
we don't develop more more skill
and this mental model we hold this
assumption and belief that it's going to
harm the relationship something is going
to go terribly awry gets reinforced
because we have no new data
to update everywhere so we hold these
beliefs and by the way one of the
reasons the course is so powerful and
thousands of alums for decades have
found it so transformational is that
they got an opportunity to experiment
with giving feedback and updating these
mental models that they hold
and have discovered that it actually
builds relationship it doesn't ruin
relationship
now one way you can you're more likely
to move into experimentation is with a
little more skill
so a big part of the book
is dedicated to some of the skills that
you need in order to be more effective
at giving feedback
there's a central model to the course
and the book called the net
and that's a very specific way of giving
somebody feedback that's both
behaviorally specific
and includes the reaction of the other
person's
behaviors
your reactions to their behaviors
so for example
my husband comes home this is now many
years ago the story's in the book many
years ago he comes home from a long day
in the valley he's been working very
hard he collapses in the chair in the
front room and grabs the newspaper i
hear him i come running out of the back
room
and i start talking oh my god you're
you're home thank god
and he does not make he does not raise
his eyes from his newspaper
and the only thing he responds with is
hmm
now that's the behavior no eye contact
and a grunt
my reaction is
i feel dismissed and i don't feel heard
and i feel hurt
but the here's the problem in an
exchange between two people there are
three realities
there's the behavior
which is there's reality number one
what's going on for andy
reality number two the behavior he's
engaging in the only reality that's
known to both of us
and there's reality number three which
is what's happening for me
and we talk about a metaphorical net
between
uh what's going on for him his reality
number one
and
the other two so i don't know what's
going on for him
but what i do
when i don't understand the concept of
the net is i say
you're not listening to me
well that assumes that i'm in his head
and i know
and i don't
you're not listening to me is over the
net and it gets worse
i feel that you don't care
first of all is not a feeling
and second of all
is an attribution
it's imputing a motive i don't know
whether he cares or not unless he says i
don't care
so until i learn to say when you make no
eye contact and the only thing i get is
a grunt i don't feel heard and that and
i feel hurt and dismissed
and i'm telling you this because it
makes me less inclined to want to be
there for you
that's the complete package of a piece
of feedback that's entirely on my side
of the net
and it's likely to make him less
defensive than saying
i feel that you're not sensitive or i
feel that you know you don't care
because by the way that's incredibly
unfair he's the most sensitive man on
the planet
if i could add a little bit to that
which is a great description
is we also say around the gsp
this is part of
the notion is that feedback is a gift
and it takes two to no one
as andy needs carol to know andy
he needs to know the effect of his
behavior
if we don't know the effect of our
behavior we're shooting in the dark and
you don't hit the target when you're
shooting
so that's why feedback is a gift when
it's given with the intention to help
each other deaf the other and to help
the relationship and if we go back to
your question about receiving feedback
by the way if you want others to be
better givers then it behooves you to
become a better receiver sure
they we say it's a gift and by the way
sometimes it's wrapped in a really ugly
wrapping really hard to tell there's
even a gift in there
right but but if you can respond to a
piece of feedback even if it's over the
net because the person didn't read the
book and they don't know what they're
doing
you can respond with curiosity and
inquiry huh what is it that i've done
and what exactly is the result of that
how is that making you feel you can push
them back
over the net
wow well thank you both for giving us
the gift of insight into how to give
better feedback from my perspective what
i hear you talking about is it's about
the approach you take it's about
understanding all parties involved and
what
information they have access to and
taking time to be deliberate
and thoughtful in giving feedback is
critical so
thank you for that and i will for one
have received many gifts that did not
appear to be gifts at first but in
hindsight they certainly were
i'm curious to get your suggestions for
how we can better connect and develop
our relationships now that so much of
our communication is virtual do you have
some suggestions for us
yeah well first of all
everything that we've been talking about
uh and everything that's in the book i
think
is
something to consider doubling down on
during this time
so
the fact is that it's
i think we've become much more
transactional as a result of the
pandemic
and much more task oriented especially
in business at the expense of
relationships so we have a lot of
contact maybe but not a whole lot of
connection
and if we want more connection then
we've got to make a little bit of time
to ask each other how are you really
doing what's really going on i have a
ceo uh that's
it in my program in my leaders in tech
program right now who starts every
meeting by having every one of his
team every member of his team start with
a two minute if you really knew me and
then he times them and for two minutes
they have to complete that phrase
that distinction between contact and
connection opened up so many
doors for me i've really been struggling
because i'm i'm thinking to myself i'm
talking to so many people i'm teaching
so many people and yet i don't feel the
same connection
that i used to and and thank you for
helping make that distinction so we have
to take the time to actually connect it
doesn't mean that we're looking at faces
on a screen you actually have to connect
with those faces
thank you
before we end i'd like to ask you the
same three questions i ask everyone who
joins me are you guys up for that
yeah sounds good yeah excellent so carol
if you were to capture the best
communication advice you ever received
as a five to seven word presentation
slide title
what would it be
i have to determine whether this really
comes down to five words
it's okay you can have a few extra uh
interpersonal success
depends on
who you're talking to and for what
purpose
okay that's a little extra but we're
going to let it slide because it's
really insightful tell me a little bit
more
um
so
one of the biggest mistakes people make
is they think one size fits all
one of the most important things
students learn in touchy-feely is the
exact opposite which is why we weren't
going to write five easy steps to being
more interpersonally affected
um
the fact is
connecting with someone else is new is
is nuanced it's idiosyncratic to that
particular relationship what works for
you and me matt to connect more deeply
may or may not be what works for david
and me
and so
to the extent that i want to be
effective in in connecting with you i've
got to take you and me and our
relationship
into consideration
in the context of the relationship are
we work colleagues are we friends
um and so i think that's kind of what's
underneath the uh
the seven words or the at nine words or
however many words i had great well
carol it is a true pleasure to call to
have you as a work colleague and a
friend so thank you
who is a communicator that you admire
and why
i'm gonna pick two people if i can sure
first person is
a therapist i had many years ago
and
laurence
was so effective because
i sensed that she really wanted to get
to know me
one thing
she was very honest and she pulled no
punches
but she was also aware of um as a
therapist would say
when their gets in the way
and when she was hooked by something i'd
say she would stop and say oh that's me
i'm sorry
and it was just wonderful
um
the other person i'm gonna name uh
actually is carol
and we've tested the communication
now for
many many years but over the last three
and a half years
um so i'm going to say this to carol
carol why i pick you
is
most the time you're clean in terms of
what you say
and second when you're not i can raise
it
and
i rarely experience you getting
defensive or explaining yourself
but you really do live with the notion
that
feedback is a gift and you're doing
something and we clean it up right away
and i find after we have cleaned it up i
feel closer to you it has built the
relationship
um so i i mean that and i uh have really
valued you as a co-author and
as
a very close friend
thank you david i'm really touched
uh
and back and right back at you um
in every regard so who do i admire
i you know the first person that sprang
to mind for me that's you know obviously
famous is barack obama
[Music]
and the reason i mean obviously he's a
great order and he's very you know he's
very succinct and articulate and just a
pleasure to listen to but the reason
he came to mind for me was too and i've
had the immense privilege and pleasure
of meeting him in person
is
that what you see is what you get
um and i mean of course he's he's got
he's a public persona and but i feel
incredibly drawn to him and the reason i
feel drawn to him is he's not afraid to
show his emotions
he's not afraid to talk about how he's
feeling
he's he has conviction and strength but
also a vulnerability and a willingness
to be wrong
that is inspiring
uh i totally agree i i i've had the
great fortune not to meet him but i met
one of his speech writers who echoes
everything that you just said so thank
you both for sharing that
so david what are the first three
ingredients that go into a successful
communication recipe from your
perspective
well i'm um
carol stole by thunder but that's oh i'm
sorry
no no it's wonderful because i'm going
to build x it's really very important
um
we sometimes communicate to get the test
done
but i want to talk about the interplay
between communication and relationships
the first
first thing is that
of the three that you asked for is i
have to take account of
this relationship
and um and not treat relationships as a
general statement
what is the other where is the other
person right now what do they need what
do i need
how
robust is our relationship
so so that's the first part i've got to
take a cover the relationship
then i need to take account of the fact
that in most of my conversations
i want to communicate in order
to build this relationship
and this isn't just with
intimate people that i have
but uh
i find for example when i go to the
store i
i do the shopping for the
household i like to have a more personal
relationship even with a clerk
and can i communicate in a way that
shows that person i see that person as
an individual
it's only a
two-minute interaction
so i want to see
communication as a way to build the
relationship
and the third one is
if i have done that and i have built a
strong relationship
i can communicate in so many more ways
i can share so much more about myself
i can even make more mistakes because i
know we have the foundation to recover
from it
so for me
the
communication has to be closely tied
with the relationship they're
intertwined
and they have to be seen together
a very powerful and important point that
communication happens within a
relationship and i like how you layer
that
description where you start with
appreciating the relationship building
the relationship and that frees you to
have a variety of different types of
communication
thank you both your insights and ideas
have been incredibly helpful to my mind
they boil down to agency introspection
and connection and especially balancing
out both thoughts
and feelings
i believe everyone who has listened in
can see why the class you helped build
and have taught for so many years has
been so successful
and speaking of success i wish you much
of it with your new book
all the best
thank you for listening to think fast
talk smart the podcast a production of
stanford graduate school of business to
learn more go to gsb.stanford.edu
please download other episodes wherever
you find your podcast